we looked at motion in terms of
displacement the example I gave you was
a velocity function I think it was
eating the negative x I've done my head
okay so in other words it's like okay
Riley knowing the speed velocity in
terms of when in the situation right in
terms of time it's asking it in terms of
what telling me in terms of where you
want okay now we're going to push him
out a little bit because velocity is one
thing but we want to climb down the
ladder another step to get to
acceleration okay now you might recall
done right this part you might recall
the way we are unpacked that
displacement velocity question that we
had before was to say if you were given
this V by definition is a derivative
what driven it is it it's the X on duty
it's how your position is changing with
respect to time okay and then we did
this little algebra intrigued by taking
the reciprocal on both sides and then
off you go okay now we need to do
something very similar with this result
here with acceleration to understand ok
now just their heads up i'm going to
show you a proof it's um one two three
four five lines five lines okay I'm
going to show it to you in a way that
develops it rather than just like okay
here's an answer and then off you guys
you can use it but you need to know this
proof okay it's kind of confusing i
remember being confused by it when I
always in year 12 so give yourself a bit
of time to understand what's going on
let's begin by definition there are two
ways that you already know for telling
me what acceleration is one of the two
ways
no in context of any kind of changing an
object ok so the first thing I could say
is just lying velocity is the first
derivative with respect to time right if
i differentiate another time then I'll
get the second derivative and that's one
of my definition so far for what
acceleration is ok but along with this
right I can I don't have to talk about
displacement if I don't want to I can
just leave it in terms of velocity force
in the acceleration connect or not they
what's the derivative that I could say
that acceleration is equal to D be on
duty it's how velocity is changing over
time ok now I'm going to go after this
guy be on detail I'm going to just take
that as much thing well what I'm trying
to do here is to get away from time
that's what I want to avoid ok I want to
UM try and get acceleration and only
have it expressed in terms of
displacement ok so usually when you got
a variable here you want to get rid of a
variable which of the rules to use that
we can take advantage of the changes
variables its chain rule right so what I
want to do is string together a pair of
derivatives that will come from this but
gets you that helps me get rid of time
ok so this has come from chain this is
vivi on something times something on dt
again i just need to choose the same
thing to go there and then chainable
will set me back there it'll all cancel
now ok so what would you like to choose
how about DX i really have that many
other options to go with right like
acceleration is what I am I've
displacement is kind of the only thing
left that I don't ok now this is good
this is good because if you have a look
at the right-hand part of that dfw t
that's one of the t's that i was trying
to get rid of that's just velocity isn't
it
so this is good this is good because now
I've gone one step and by the way this
is an important result I'll refer to it
again in a second this is acceleration
in terms of velocity acceleration in
terms of awesome so I haven't got it in
terms of displacement yet but this line
by itself this is still relevant because
there are some situations where the
acceleration acting on you depends on
how fast you're going okay for instance
if you're lucky enough to be very very
fit and you can run really fast that you
will know when you're running against
the wind or with the wind there's a real
difference because what are you
experiencing at that time you're
experiencing the resistance of air in
your face right the faster you're going
that will change the acceleration act on
your body so this is an important one
but I want to go a little bit further I
want to turn this into just a single
derivative rather than another function
and driven together okay now this next
steps a bit weird but I want you to
notice see how here we use this chain of
DX's and these cancel to get to hear
right well here there's a chain here
that's sort of half words there and the
other half is missing so if this is DV
up here I want to have a DV down here
does that make sense so I want a D on DV
statement let's get a match up with this
DV or DX okay so something goes in here
and multiplies for these TVs will cancel
hmm pause for a second pause DVR DX is
here so so what this is is I'll asking
for the primitive function of this I'm
asking for the primitive ok what thing
if i differentiate it lands me on V and
the answer is half v square right or B
squared up to that's how you would state
would usually say poppy
so where where did I get this line from
this is again remember this is a bit
weird it's a bit counterintuitive okay
for starters I've just got this DV on
the exco down here right but I've chosen
to put TV down you're living on it so
that I can get rid of this DVD does that
make sense but Deion DB of what will
give me V and the answer is I'm asking
for the primitive function which is half
the primitive with respect to time but
I'm not with respect to time anymore
very good okay so now that I've done
that the other than that what this
really is is the derivative of this with
respect to V times the derivative of
this with respect to X but my chain here
once again right so this is the
derivative of this with respect to X and
bam I've got a single review okay so
this this is a bit weird sorry for
Saigon you but this is my new statement
for acceleration can i right can I write
D on DX of half a square yeah yeah same
thing in just the same way that we write
dy or DX right but that's really way of
saying okay I'm applying the
differential operator differentiate and
the thing of differentiating is why I
think we just check that up there
because this shows you are this quantity
and this quantity how are they changing
a relation to each other whereas this is
more saying okay you've got a thing a
function that behaves in a particular
way and I want you to do something to it
so even though these are the same the
emphasis is a little bit different ok
now I ask you to get the referees
cheater right so if you will come back
to this in second if you are there
remember we've been an extension one
mission for at least a few days in our
case you're going to have to scroll all
the way past the tutu inner pages and
then here in the top right hand corner
you'll find this guy ok so you can see
there are these four ways of staking
acceleration ok I kind of feel like this
is the most intuitive one acceleration
by definition is how is velocity
changing
but of course because velocity itself is
a derivative that means that
acceleration is the second derivative
and then we just develop these two by
sort of mucking around with chain r we
actually did it twice okay the first
change gets you to this the first chain
rule the second chain will gets you to
hear okay now five lines there were
weird lines right this proof here you
need to be able to do this now the
caveat is or sort of the help it can get
is it because this is on this is on the
this is on the reference to okay so you
do not need to start where we started
and actually develop this thing and
think about it the way mathematicians
developed this you can actually start
from here just that as your result and
you can climb back and do just regular
old chain rule rather than think I'll
conjure up some DVD or some d x-ray you
can go that way and that proof is
actually much simpler okay but it's
exactly it's an identical proof just in
reverse order and you need to know that
proof it's accessible when they ask you
that could say prove that yes yeah in
Reverse yeah because this this is this
is what you've got right and you can
just you can just step back through you
can say well I can differentiate this
thing with respect to be and that will
give me V give me 0 DX and then this
thing will v by definition is the Exxon
DT so i can write that as the xmt and
then the chains are you Klaus you can do
it anyway line it would still cost as
you to prove but this is a much hard way
to do it this is where managers had to
develop this right where is you you have
the luxury of actually knowing what the
result is so in much the same way that a
trig identity is like oh ok I'll give
you what they are and you just tell me a
to be right well you know you know what
is now so you can just use that ok